en 1998 laurent beaudoin est au salon de
farnborough en angleterre
c'est à ce moment que naît le rêve de la
cseries
le gendre de joseph armand bombardier et
patron de l'entreprise familiale veut
jouer dans la cour des grands il dévoile
les plans du br j x1 avions de 100 à 115
places aux clients régionaux
on veut pas les heures d éventuellement
être la demande doit être là pour un
avion plus grand mais il est risqué
d'affronter des géants comme boeing et
airbus
quand laurent beaudoin et remplacer le
br j x et rapidement abandonné le projet
rené en 2004 sous le nom de sissi with
une relance qui coïncide avec le retour
des besoins à la tête de bombardier
l'avion sera assemblé à mirabel
mais la tâche s'avère encore une fois
colossal des projets d'envergure comme
la série cc des projets où il va voir à
différentes périodes d incertitude il
faudra attendre à 2013 avant d'assister
au baptême de l'air de l'avion beaucoup
de coups d'arrêts de travail beaucoup de
sacrifices pour moi ça fait quatre ans
que je sors la cseries donc à cet
extincteur cie ce matin
l'appareil impressionne le plus moderne
le plus économique et le moins bruyant
de sa catégorie
mais les concurrents airbus et boeing
sont agressés fait se lance dans une
guerre de prix la cseries ne se vend pas
critiqué pierre beaudoin quitte la
direction de bombardier
la compagnie est au bord du gouffre et
québec doit voler à son secours
ce contexte le grunge québec dgeq 3 dont
1 1 milliard de dollars américains
malgré de nouvelles commandes de delta
puis d'air canada le ciel tarde à
s'éclaircir pour bombardier en 2017
washington impose des droits
compensateurs ans l'entreprise à
l'automne
airbus prend le contrôle de la cseries
aujourd'hui la cseries repose sur des
bases solides et est promis à un avenir
brillant
l'année suivante l'appareil change de
nom et devient la 220 un changement qui
marque la prise de contrôle européenne
du programme
ça nous fait tous un petit quelque chose
c'est toute cette histoire bien sûr
accroché nous sommes un petit deuil 22
ans et des milliards de dollars plus
tard c'est la fin de l'aventuré et du
rêve de la cseries ici sébastien
desrosiers inde au canada
morin